you
so the next speaker is Christian to
tville and Christian is a data scientist
at the unbelievable machine company is
one of the sponsors of pi data it's a
cloud service provider located in Berlin
and before that he co-founded a start-up
in game analytics in Copenhagen and he's
going to be talking to us today about
low rank matrix approximations with
Python um thanks a lot for the
introduction thank you all right so I'm
first of all the question look you and
there's no what a low rank matrix
approximation is could you please raise
your hand okay most of you who does not
know what it is okay we just know what
k-means clustering is or a sort of it
and okay perfect that's great and PC a
principal component analysis perfect
perfect great so at the end of the talk
I hope you'll all have seating similar
way as I do it that k-means clustering
is also just the matrix matrix
approximation so that's also one of the
one of the key conclusions I single to
start any on so let me start with what
works back to the next say 30 minutes so
first of all start with some brief
introduction into what the lowering
matrix approximation is what matrix
factorization is and then it will
concentrate a bit about in the different
masses that exist so there's a huge
amount of different methods obviously I
cannot talk about all of these only on a
very small amount of them and i will
also talk a bit about the implementation
pipes no please and then i will conclude
with a couple of examples and some
confusion so first of all observations
so m data matrix factorization has
become a super important tool in many
different fields so you can see a lot of
examples for this over the last few
years for example when you have a look
at the ratings of a movies so there you
always so they usually have matrix which
you have in each row for example a movie
and each column you have a user and its
engines ratings so if you think about
the matrix it's huge matrix and by
itself you can really make that much use
of it but then what you often try to do
is try to sort of fact
rise it or approximated to extract some
meaning out of matrix and there are
other examples gene expression data
digital images so you can store and
images in the matrix by having each
column or the pixel information off the
image and then each row so each column
and well then each entry corresponds to
the color value of one of the pixels and
in the columns you have all the
different images so and obviously graphs
too so you can and store all information
from a graph into an adjacency matrix so
brief introduction so what is matrix
factorization so let's assume you have a
matrix V and the goal of matrix
factorization is actually very very
simple so the only thing that you want
to do is you want to find two matrices
W&H so that you can approximate your
matrix v by the dot product of wh so
that's it and then obviously for a lot
of different applications and math sets
the rank of WH might change but but this
equation here this is actually all the
basis of matrix factorization so why the
heck would you want to do that why do
you want to represent some large matrix
by some possibly lower rank matrices wnh
so they're a couple of interesting
things you can do with the matrix
factorization afterwards so um two of
the things I want to talk about in this
talk the first thing is that you can
transform data by doing that so that
seems sort of obvious s so first you
have the large matrix and then you
factorize it into two lower rank
matrices so somehow you transform the
data and later I want to talk about what
the benefit of this is and you can also
compress data so if the rank of the
matrix this is lower than the rank of
the original matrix obviously you sort
of lose some information or you compress
data and then afterwards you can always
use these factorized matrices for for
example information retrieval pattern
recognition data mining
one of the one of the first steps you
would always want to do when you're
dealing with huge data or huge data
matrix usually factor accident first
mathematically this looks really really
simple as I SAT so basically what you
have you are connecting sweetie you
approximated by multiplying wh so here's
the matrix B you have you you have a lot
of columns and Allah grows so and this
is then the factorization that you're
interested in which has a lower range so
the matrix W the column rank is lower
than the column rank raphy and 4-h you
see that the row rank of H is lower than
the row rank of V & M usually so I'm
here you have a value K so basically
this and shows your number number of
columns that you have for W this is
usually for lowering approximations much
much lower than the actual rank of you
otherwise wouldn't make that much sense
and now when you have a look at
individual elements of the different
matrices so let's have a look at the
element of the matrix V at the second
row the first column this is now the
product of the second row of W and the
fourth column of H so very very simple
right so now you represent one entry of
V by multiplication of a row and a
column in another matrix and this is a
formula for that so so far you didn't
gain anything from it but this is just
how it works and probably more
importantly what you can also do or
following from that is that when you
want to represent a complete column of V
and you simply multiply the column of V
out use you can represent it by the
matrix w x the fourth column of h from
that you can see a few things so the
first is that somehow now you
represented the 4th column of me by only
the entries in age so be Chris this
matrix W is just a new basis that you
now use to describe your data in so the
the matrix W now always stays the same
and for each of the different data
samples that you have for me
in the columns you now have a different
set of coefficients which now describe
this particular data set data sample and
this and how it looks like so basically
you take the first row of h multiplied
by the or the first row first column of
h entry and multiply by the first column
of w and then you sum up the other
values through alright so from that you
could already see that matrix
factorization is nothing else as data
transformation so you take the data
transform it into something else and
then the outcome is for example this age
right now I have a completely different
representation for the same data and if
you choose a lower rank then you can
also compress a date so instead of
having for example for this vide is
large matrix no end up with this rather
smaller matrix h and this is the most
common form so you said we should equal
the product of WH and for finding this
kind of approximation the now it's just
a broad range of different methods so
then you could also want to ok why the
hell others so many different ways of
approximating this matrix V I mean
wouldn't it be sufficient to just the
one of these masters right so just try
to find a master that gives you the best
possible approximation of me assuming a
certain ring that you want to achieve
but each of this different master data
listed here for example k-means
clustering SVD a non-negative matrix
factorization they all yield a different
view a unique view on the same data so
you always end up with solve a different
representation of the same data and all
these different representations have
different benefits and actually useful
for different paths and endeavor
therefore also that the goal of
approximating the matrix it's not always
really the goal of finding the best
possible approximation it's more the
goal of finding the approximation that
is most useful for the task a task at
hand um so let's have a look for example
i'm at k means clustering which is which
is am obviously on
look it's not really a matrix
factorization approach so its most
well-known is a baseline class rank
massive right so when you want to apply
k-means clustering usually your task is
you have a lot of you know data samples
in some space and you assume the data
samples are Gaussian distributed so you
say okay i want i'm looking for K
clusters then you run k-means clustering
and the outcome of that is a couple of
cluster centroids and the assignments of
your data points to the different
cluster centroids so this is what he
means is doing and but if you can
formulate it as a matrix factorization
tasks you receive that we have the same
kind of formulation so that's just we
now minus W times H so this is a
formulation this is our objective
function so this is what we want to
minimize we want to approximate v as
best as possible but in the case of key
means we impose certain constraints on
the approximation and the constraints
are such that we say that H should be
either 0 or 1 and that each column in H
should sum up to 1 so what what what
does that mean so basically am basically
we impose a very very hard constraint on
this matrix factorization and at the end
if you apply k-means we end up with sort
of a clustering of the data points and
for sake of completeness or k-means is
usually optimized using an expectation
maximization schema and the optimal
partitioning 40 means is np-hard so the
problem is rather difficult and the goal
is to group similar data points so am so
wise King means clustering matrix
factorization so let's have a look at
this schematic view of it so here you
have the am proficient vectors M H so
labeled here a so am what you see here
in each column you have all these all
zeros just one of the entrances one so
what does it mean we say we now want to
represent our data samples by cluster
centroids and they should be assigned to
exactly one cluster centroids the
cluster centroids are computed as a
product of the matrix X and the matrix B
the matrix
now contains our our original data set
original data samples and the matrix B
realizes the mapping of this original
data set onto our set of K cluster
centroids so at the end you end up with
the matrix and W that has in each column
the cluster centroids and the matrix h
where you have the assignment vectors so
this is why you can actually easily see
that commune slathering is nothing else
the matrix approximation or matrix
factorization so basically you always
realize an assignment of data points X
to a set of cluster centroids right and
this is just by unfolding these
constraints and otherwise using that
formula so here you can see an example
how that looks like for saddle facial
images so let's assume we want to
approximate this particular facial image
here by MK means partitioning or by a
combination of basis vectors and so how
would that look like so um we now have
half a couple of basis vectors here
which correspond to these key means
cluster centroid directors and all of
these are in the linear combination all
of them are zero except for one which is
the one which is closest to the original
data point that we put into this and
then we say okay we were constructed by
just taking this one so is one x this
guy here and then you enter with sort of
some representation of a facial image or
some some approximation of a facial
image here what you can also see for
that that k-means is for a lot of cases
I really ideal because here you can see
okay this representation doesn't really
look like face anymore so the mean of
some I don't know different different
faces but that's not the point the point
is only that you can easily can
approximate or or can express k-means
clustering dramatic virtualization right
and so how would that look like in pison
so we developed in 2010 at the
fraunhofer institute in bond and at the
university of bonn a little tool box hi
map it's called for matrix factorization
and have included a lot of different
matrix factorization math it's also a
lot that you cannot really
the two boxes so he means obviously not
I mean it's very common method I think
so and the toolbox it supports a vast
number of different methods it also
supports hdf5 by our h 5 pi and also
sparse matrices and it it doesn't
support hdf5 and sparse matrices for all
the masses that has some technical
reasons and also sometimes for certain
assets even if you put as fast matrix
into it you end up with the dense matrix
so therefore it doesn't really make
sense to apply it there anymore anyhow
so how does work is really really simple
you simply create a matrix here which is
very simple it contains only three
columns then you just apply the master
to it you set the number of iterations
and then at the end you can compute the
approximation by having a look at the
dot product of W and H right so um and
one of the things that you also often
would like to do is to map existing data
onto the models that you have already
computed right so so so so this is also
very very common to do for clustering k
matrix factorization and a lot of other
of these tasks and here it's also very
very simple so what you do for your test
data you simply initialize in UK means
model and but now you submitted the test
data you said again the number of basis
vectors that you would like to have but
then you assign the basis vectors that
you computed before to just one of the
basis vector of the test model and then
you just tell the factorization not to
compute w at all so basically you're
just interested in optimizing for H
which is which is in that particular
case the same as computing the distance
of the data that you put into it to all
the different basis vectors but this of
course can vary for different methods
and then at the end you have an
approximation of your test data using
all their you can also use of course the
basis vectors that you have used before
right so so that was what Keynes
classroom as I said there are a lot of
different masses that are useful for
different tasks and K means clustering
is always used in the Cornishman when
you want to group data when your
interests okay how how can I represent
my data in such a way that I find data
that
that belongs to a certain class the
region then you use key means and other
masses for example PCA i think is
probably the most well-known matrix
factorization message that exists or SVD
and there again the task is almost the
same so so again you would like to like
to find the best boss possible
approximation of V by the probe of W and
H but in the case of PCA the
restrictions are no different so the
constraints that you impose on the
factorization again completely different
so you say that W and should be
constructed out of the singular vectors
of V and the matrix should be orthogonal
so in principle what you say okay you're
looking for the eigenvectors right you
want to find the best possible basis in
order to represent V so this is what PCA
is doing and then you don't have any
constraint on the coefficient matrix H
so that can be not negative positive it
does really matter or negative and
exactly so am usually PCA violates non
negativity so you can really control
that this makes it not really the ideal
choice for data analysis so it's the
data scientist um it really is really
bit awkward I mean it's always only good
for my opinion for um for compression or
for filtering out noise that's when you
usually would like to apply PCA and and
also you can also see that when you have
a look at the different approximations
that you would get as the outcome of
applying PCA to a facial image or set of
facial images and again we use PI map so
the usage is exactly the same as before
you just switch the masa then you tell
it to factorize and then the
approximation is again just the dot
product of wh mm and you can also see
how the data approximation then looks
like so so this is the facial image that
you are the first and then for PCA I
mean usually what you get you get a
pretty good approximation and this is
simply because PCA is optimum PCA or SVG
we'll give you for any rank a that you
are looking for it with if you always
the most optical data representation in
sense of minimizing and you are pure
your objective function but this does
not mean that it is optimal in terms of
interpretation in terms of extracting
valuable information from it so for
example the basis vectors are usually
not enter critical which is a big
disadvantage in data science so you
cannot assign any meaning to this basis
vectors here another interesting and
over the last year's rather common
method is non-negative matrix
factorization and again you receive the
basic form of obviously it's the same
right so I now repeated that so many
times it is always the same as always v
minus W times H but this time again and
you impose different constraints now you
say ok I want to constrain W&H in such a
way that they should be non-negative and
simply by imposing that constraint you
again end up with a completely different
view on the same data so it completely
different approximations and a different
result also from in terms of when you
want to interpret the data all right so
um some details on nmf and there is said
to be a global optimal so solution to
that but there is no algorithm to
actually find it and the exact nmf
chrome is also empty hard and what is it
very interesting about NM f is that this
non negativity constrained this results
in sort of a path based representation
or this often results in the path based
representation of your data which
samsung which is also bit unique right
so for k-means clustering you have the
representation of these cluster
centroids then you can represent each
data point by just one example data
point for pca you don't have anything
it's just sort of the most optimal
representation and now for NM f you have
a representation by parts so now you can
reconstruct your data by am sort of
summing up different parts of your basis
vectors so let's have a look how
looks for the facial images here so um
it's a sort of visible so um there are
also some other examples where the parts
actually look a bit better I think this
is probably an artifact of the data set
that I used you so but what you can see
from that is that instead of now having
some images which which represent all is
the complete face or or represent
individual you end up with only parts of
the face being available so for example
here you could maybe say this is maybe
the nose a bird and here we have an ear
and then if you think about it so now
you are interested in a non-negative and
combination of this different parts so
you take zero times this guy may be in
here now so maybe that's part of the
image third pic maybe once this
particular image and then your evony
okay you might also want to have up in
here once you want to reconstruct an ear
in your image so then you can also put a
certain amount of this image into the
image and at the end you end up with
fairly good approximation of your data
set but interestingly when you then have
a look at the coefficient vectors you
can always see okay i was using parts of
this image and parts of this image and
if you can interpret these images which
you can often do then you have pretty
good understanding about what you're
actually seeing here so you can
reconstruct data by individual parts
which is sort of hidden in the data
right and the last example for these
matrix factorization math so once talked
about is called it's called act upon
analysis hmm this I belief is really
less well known so was developed in 1994
by cut lon Reiman and um it's a it's a
fairly interesting mass that I saying in
terms of the outcome of the
factorization of this so the form mostly
stays the same so here's no slight
difference so instead of just having wh
you also incorporate the original data
matrix V into this so what does it mean
w is restricted to convexity so that
means all entries in w have to be larger
or have to be non-negative and each
column needs to
21 so this is sort of a probabilistic
combination of your input data points
right and then for H you have the same
constraint so it's also come back to the
constraint it means you restrict it to
non negativity and then you also sum up
the concept to sum up to 1 so that's
again a probabilistic representation so
what is the outcome of this is that
usually these archetypes or the basis
vector of yours are the most extreme
data points so for the facial images you
will end up as you can also hear the
first of all what's interesting you end
up with actually actually existing
images so all these guys really exist in
the database and these are all images
that that that we have in our data set
so that's the first interesting
observation the second interesting
observation is that these images the
basis vectors are the most extreme data
points in the sense that they have the
highest pairwise distance between them
so what what does that mean so when you
have a look at the first two images
these two guys have the largest distance
between them of all the images in the
data set so these are polar opposites
right so you can think about it if you
would add more and more images to the
data set that would show you all
different no kinds of human faces you
will at the end end up with sort of the
ACT typical representations of human
faces and here these guys are really
extreme in the sense because this guy's
rather pale and here the lighting
conditions maybe are not as good so his
skin colors were the doc so what you see
from that that they really pull opposite
and both guys don't have that much hair
right so which is also interesting they
even like the hair and then it goes
further so these guys have a lot of hair
here and then it's also quite pale quite
quite asking so so so what you can see
from that so and the third guy actually
also has sort of the highest possible
distance to the first two guys and then
take the force guy and he's also having
a very high distance to the others right
so that's the first thing so you end up
with basis vectors that correspond to
serve the most extreme data points the
second interesting thing is you
represent then your data so the cool
fish
vectors the h are also restricted to
convexity so what does that mean
basically you now can represent each of
your facial images that you have asked
the probabilistic combination of all
these archetypes so you can say with the
probability of 0.35 percent this guy is
that guy and with the probability of 0.2
percent that guy and with probability of
0.1 percent at the other one so so
you're not saying that it is this person
but that it contains aspects of it so
this is a great tool for data analysis
because now you're able of representing
data by something which is interpretable
so you can interpret these facial images
this is something that you cannot do
with PCA with k-means is also really
really difficult to do and with nmif
okay you have this part which which
things are also great now you can
interpret data and also you can
represent data in a stochastic way all
right so these are these are probably
the two most interesting things about
that and mmm so overall and just to just
to quickly summarize the different
masses right so here we have again every
single one on one slide and the list is
actually much much longer so here I only
mentioned the four most common methods
there are a lot more masses that can
easily expressed as matrix factorization
as a common form and this also then
obviously makes matrix factorization or
lowering approximations one of the most
useful data exploration to simply
because all these methods are and lowing
lowing matrix approximations and here
you can see is also actually quite funny
when you look at the list right so I
never really checked but I would assume
that all possible constraints that you
can impose on either of the matrices wnh
somehow is manifested in a well known
method used for data analysis so here
you have no constraints almost no
constraints on w NH so then you have pca
and I ignore sort of the the auto
granola key constraint simply because if
you're looking for the most optimal
representation for and PCA it will
always be in this orbital matrix so
that's just how it is and then for
communes class
you have you have these two constraints
so zero you restrict h20 and one and it
should the column should sum up to 1
right so there's only one constraint
which imposed on H in fact for nmf it's
non negativity for both and then for
Octavio analysis it's non negativity and
convexity so it already has some parts
of k-means clustering here so you have
for October analysis you restrict H it
should sum up to 1 like in King needs
and then you say okay it should be
non-negative this is like an like an
animal right so you can see this all
these methods are also some are related
to each other but they differ on on on
on the different constraints and of
course the way they are optimized is
also always different right so this is
because different constraints actually
facilitate different ways of optimizing
them and what's probably also important
to note is that that the the top of the
constraint is that you will impose the
more difficulties actually is usually to
solve these approximations so a lot of
research also went over the last years
into finding efficient approximations to
active analysis or in a metaphor other
methods to make them useful or suitable
for large data and just quickly I'm as I
spoke about large data so at the
beginning I mentioned that these PI IMF
and the pison matrix factorization shoe
box also works with HT of 5 4 h 5 pi it
does and the way it works is this is
actually rather simple so um you can
just use it the same way as used before
so you just saw you so this is the
function call here so this is all the
same the only thing that you do or that
you have to keep in mind is that you
simply assign the the matrices wh you
have to initialize them first in a h55
file and then assign them before the
factorization then Prime I've realized
okay there's already a matrix it's on
this i will use that one and then also
keeps attention that and not too much
memory is consumed on the way again it
doesn't really work with all the masses
so there are still
some methods that sort of suffer from
that intermediate blow up singing which
often happens for a lot of these methods
that sometimes during the optimization
you have to do some artists
multiplication that will end up with
real gigantic matrices so while this is
suited for doing matrix factorization
for very large data and not all the
methods are suited to it and another
example where we actually applied these
things so this was in 2010 we did some
analysis on world of warcraft gills so
what we wanted to find out we wanted to
find out okay so what's the sort of
social evolution of these skills how do
they change your attack or can we find a
representation of these skills that is
sort of interpretable that we can really
analyze them as you can sing about world
of warcraft was at that time actually a
highly successful game I think it's
still but doesn't have that 12 million
users as it used to be and here we
analyzed I don't know there's a number
100 million 70 dimensional data points
or something like that so it's quite
some large matrix I mean obviously
nowadays you have much much louder
matrices but this could also be easily
done on a single machine I was outgoing
too much and although the data never
fitted into memory right so um yeah and
and and as his head so so what we did
apply here was actually an approximation
of this archetype analysis which is
called simplex volley maximization which
which which which just delivers to
really really fast approximation to it
all right so as to take home message
effectively a lot of mass it's and data
analysis so including clustering and so
on nothing else as matrix approximation
methods they differ in the constraints
that you impose on them and
interestingly the constraint shape the
outcome of these masses to I mean I mean
this is this is is probably the most
interesting take-home message and in
general it's a super effective tool for
data exploration so there are a lot of
methods I mean suited for you know when
you are when you're looking for a
particular thing there
certainly as a data exploration way or a
matrix factorization method for doing
that you won't have always end up with
something that that is really super
super helpful but a lot of these methods
are at least when you when you are when
you're dealing with data for the first
time and if you want to have a look at
the pies implementation of course very
welcome thanks a lot for your attention
and questions are welcome
so we have the plenty of time for
questions how is the limitation any
other part so the question is if
Christian is even PMF so it contains a
lot of differential factorization method
and the question is how does the speed
and performance compared to two other
methods and that's a good question to be
honest for for the standard methods we
never really measured I think this is I
would assume other methods are more
other message have a higher speed from
from other libraries but what was far
more important was actually to implement
the methods which do not yet have an
implementation but I would also be
interested actually in measuring the
speed and performance against other
libraries definitely definitely yeah and
the question was what is going on under
the hood and IMF if it is using fort on
libraries and see libraries orbit using
Titan and we mostly use numpy and
Fortran which is basically Park and
Blass and all these things obviously so
there is not much Pisan going on so we
don't have any for loops or everything
is vectorized so I think with respect to
that performs probably quite good anja
sure if it's paralyzed no it's not
paralyzed we had for some of the mesons
a parallel implementation running
running on hadoop but this was only for
some other experiments with it we never
released that but that might also be
interesting for future I just also be
very often as tankers and branch sure
yeah the question was if we amp IMF also
using tensors so it tends is just the
high dimensional matrix and and
intention factorization so we also did
some work on that in the past we also
considered it for for high math but we
never really implemented anything
because we also know that everything
gets so different once you go for a
tensor and as you also set a new high
there's no good representation of a
dancer I mean at least when I looked
last time which was four years ago but
but I would be very interested in also
hear more about that but yeah good
pressure yep so this all seems to be a
loss space which is not so good for one
regulation systems or something like
that because they usually open feedback
um okay um the question was if we had to
look at other loss functions apart from
the superbeings norm that we are usually
using and to be honest not really i
recently supervise the master's thesis
on SVD plus plus which would be a
recommendation matrix factorization
massive and they're using I'm really
sure actually they use this into the
same loss function but some other
regulations but honestly I'm no more
questions okay if there's if there's no
more questions let's thank Kristian once
again
you
you